I'm gonna kiss you on the mouth by the
end of this I would knock your toaster
back I'm a huge pink wine fan um dry
it's dry I typically only buy bottles of
wine there are at least $15 I think I'll
be able to identify like a white versus
a red I can tell if it tastes good to me
or not but I don't know if that equates
to cheap versus expensive what you're
supposed to yes but I'm not gonna do
that that's that's not attractive oh you
can't own it's a cheap wine when it kind
of hurts a little when you drink it yeah
you know what mine's got no legs I'm
already going cheap this is cheap I even
taste it yet oh there's like tons of
bits your sediment running it's like
kombucha wine not the biggest fan of
particles in mine in my drinks it smells
bad and it tastes bad so I'm just gonna
say it's cheap I heard that the color
the more brown it is the older it is
supposedly and it doesn't explain it is
expensive I'm going expanding - are you
kidding me hey we flick it up flip
flopper me or as long as I end up on the
right side I'm fine oh it has all the
sediment cuz it's oh oh it's delicious
Oh guys this is a nice one I highly
recommended oh man now I'm on the yard
honey I'm gonna yeah I definitely taste
it oh here Layton you have to like
really like get into it I get the swirl
late you got to smell it this is a good
one I like this one I've tasted this
before definitely I'm gonna go with
cheap it's very fruity
it is great I'm listening to her she
sounds like she knows was talked about
yeah we say cheap I'm good on that I'm a
refined palate now the regular girl is
going we know this Oh next I'm sorry I
need to learn when you teach in your
ways bigger bigger gulps
wait there's something in my let me get
it out hey that's cheap and nasty are
you liking the smell do you know I can't
stop making his face you know I kind of
like this one which makes me think it's
cheap it smells like burnt tires mmm no
gross cheap and gross when I take a
bigger gulp it's a little wincing and if
it's expensive I'm very I don't have
good taste this one doesn't have any
crust at the bottom so it's cheap
interesting that's not worth it does
that qualify as cheap if you're made of
money it's cheap you go thank you not
I'm not gonna drink that Jenny but you
shouldn't you shouldn't you're better
than this Ned this looks like somebody
peed in my cup whoa that's interesting
good news it's also lukewarm it's got
some flavor I don't know if I like that
flavor but it's a lot of it my mouth is
still trying to figure out how it feels
about it
it tastes like buttered popcorn if you
say hahaha one was that cheap this
tastes like a one my mom would drink
I bet because I don't like it it's
expensive okay exactly - we're gonna go
son I think it's too smooth and a
non-drinking it's expensive is she I'm
gonna guess like a hundred and thirty
one three maybe that's why it's got
those extra cents because we can't
afford them it doesn't taste expensive I
mean for me happy was like a four dollar
bottle Wow we learned what we already
know we're good at drinking wine are we
good at identifying it yes who hears
doesn't matter we're good at drinking it